[Music]
foreign
have you ever wondered how old Godzilla
really is well the exact age of the
G-Man depends on his different
incarnations and versions and here in
this video we will list down the 10
oldest Godzillas as seen in their last
appearances in their respective movies
as well as timelines so let's get to it
foreign
Godzilla while Shin Godzilla is one of
the most powerful and surely one of the
most terrifying and largest incarnations
of the G-Man he is also the youngest
with a life span of only a few days to a
couple of weeks old as we have seen in
the movie him rapidly developing and
evolving from one form to another in a
matter of days the first form and
previous protoforms of his might have
taken a few more days beforehand to
develop and so we will put him at least
a week old
number nine Godzilla Jr baby Godzilla
hatch from a godzillasaurus egg on
adonowa island that was found in a
Pteranodon Nest guarded over by an
irradiated Pteranodon called Rodan who
saw baby Godzilla as his younger brother
the baby hatch in 1993 and was aptly
named Godzilla Junior and by the time of
their battle with destroyer in 1995 the
small fledgling Gojira would have only
been around two to three years of age
number eight Space Godzilla space
Godzilla's Origins have always been
murky it is acknowledged that he is a
clone of Godzilla from outer space but a
specific facts of his development is
hazy bits of Godzilla's DNA were held
into space and transformed after being
eaten up by a black hole and later
emerged from a white hole as space
Godzilla but it would have either been
Godzilla's DNA carried by Mothra or by
biolante's death either way his maximum
age would only be around 5 years old
number 7 the TriStar Godzilla the 1998
Godzilla was a big deformed marine
iguana born from a nuclear testing in
French polynesia's angel Islands while
it is still an egg because the
experiment was conducted in the summer
of 1968 the creature grew over a 30-year
period his irradiated genes allowed him
to grow to a height of almost 60 meters
or 200 feet even though this version
died the same few days after making
landfall in New York he would still be
around 30 years given the immaturity
period
number six gmk Godzilla the Godzilla in
gmk is a malignant monster formed from
the Restless Souls of people died as a
result of the Japanese military's acts
during World War II which have
congregated inside Godzilla's body and
who arrived in modern day Japan to seek
vengeance upon the nation so to say this
Godzilla that is reform would be as old
as his demise to form which would put it
around 47 years of age
number five heisei Godzilla it is
theorized that in the heisei era that
Godzilla and his ilk are descendants of
a dinosaur species gold godzillasaurus
which survived the demise of the
dinosaurs at the end of the Cretaceous
Period the godzillasaurus that would
later become Godzilla lived on Lagos
Island prior to World War II and was
altered by radioactive fallout so by the
end of the battle against destoroya this
Godzilla would have been around 80 to 90
years old
number four Godzilla singular Point
although little is known about the
nature of this Godzilla and where he
came from it is presumed that Godzilla
has been around for several centuries
because he appears in many Legends and
myths implying that he has interacted
with Humanity previously at various
stages of his life prior to his exposure
to the archetypal element that
transformed him into a bipedal dinosaur
in Kaiju so he is definitely between 500
to 1000 years of age
number three Godzilla Earth Godzilla
Earth is thought to be a plant-based
mutant that consume a tremendous amount
of metal elements throughout its
development and became a moving organism
that is indestructible slowly growing
over time this Godzilla like those and
the most of us and the shin continuities
has a new redesigned origin and he is
believed to be the end product of
natural selection on Earth and has gone
on to live and Conquer The Globe for 20
000 years from the 21st century till the
events of the planet eater in the future
number two show a Godzilla it is
proposed in the original Godzilla that
he was an ancient transitional reptile
connected to both land and sea reptiles
that slept deep underground for millions
of years until being disturbed by an
American hydrogen bomb test the second
Godzilla is also a member of the same
species and like his predecessor he was
presumably awoken by an American
hydrogen bomb test this puts them both
in the range of 65 to 100 million years
of age
and number one the Monster vs Godzilla
in the monsterverse comics Godzilla
Awakening the prequel to Godzilla the
movie The G-Man is explained to be an
ancient life form from the Permian
period which deviates from the
previously accepted origin tale of him
being deformed by the hydrogen bomb this
origin story would definitely put the
monster verse version as the oldest
Godzilla a super species being more than
252 million years of age and living
through many ages of the earth and also
coexisting with other super species
called Titans
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam